it's a little bit of an update we are
uh you know at a kind of an interesting
moment with unity twitter has of course
said nothing yet about why it is that it
suspended our account it has ignored the
appeal that we've
filed and it's just now gone silent and
um increasingly i think the only
explanation for this behavior
is political we found no evidence of the
things that we were rumored to have
engaged in
when eric talked to jack and you know
the things that were spread online we
are
not russian bots we did not register
large numbers of accounts in order to
trend a hashtag um so anyway
at some level i think we are discovering
um
that you know twitter is not the ghost
in the machine
the ghost is the machine it has its
thumb on the scales
it is adjusting the way democracy works
it is deciding
what a legitimate political perspective
is and what it isn't and it favors the
duopoly which is not surprising
because of course it has
disproportionate influence over how we
are to be governed through that duopoly
so what the hell are we going to do i
mean this is this is this is
um an impossibly dangerous force and
what i fear is that it is going to
prevent any kind of change
that is not seen by the duopoly as in
its interest
and that that change has become
increasingly essential and on a short
time scale
so that is uh roughly where we find
ourselves
um we are still forging ahead i am
hopeful
um we have begun to interact with joe
jorgensen i'm hoping she will come on
our campfire and talk to us about the
possible partnership between
libertarians
and the unity movement she is skeptical
but
um i believe when she sees uh
what our perspective really is that she
might well
be willing to partner